demandez aux as we lundi dernier ou
plutôt lundi de la semaine dernière
après dix jours les jours d'activités
illégales dans notre vie capitale les
abîmes des passages frontaliers le
gouvernement fédéral a évoqué la loi sur
les mesures d'urgence
c'était une décision responsable et
nécessaire nous avons agi ainsi guidé
par trois principes surtout premièrement
à rétablir la paix l'ordre social
deuxièmement
agir de façon correcte troisièmement
nous assurer que c'était limité dans le
temps
le premier point l'arrêt que rétablir la
paix dans nos rues et la confiance dans
les institutions
c'était vraiment en tête de liste la
sécurité publique tels que l'emploi et
hôtels mais aussi était au risque les
gendarmes ni les petits commerçants
ferment leurs portes les usines arrêtait
les chaînes d'assemblage et la
circulation des billets étaient bloqués
aux frontières
ottawa que magna il ya des preuves de
l'existence de gens qui veulent apporter
habitat est à la démocratie canadienne
lors par six patients
pouvaient augmenter le potentiel de
violence et de perturbation par de
l'agitation sociale nous avons voulu
appuyer des provinces et les
municipalités afin qu'ils puissent
maîtriser la situation mais avec le
temps de semaine en semaine il est
devenu évident que les autorités locales
et provinciales avaient besoin de plus
d'outils dans leur carquois fin d'août
appliquer la loi et protéger les
canadiens c'est exactement ce que la loi
sur les mesures d'urgence prévoit la
semaine dernière le gouvernement fédéral
a évoqué la loi sur les mesures
d'urgence parce que les autorités
locales et provinciales avaient besoin
de plus d'outils pour protéger les
canadiens comme le chef intérimaire
belle du service de police d'ottawa l'a
dit la loi sur les mesures d'urgence a
été un point tournant pour mettre fin de
l'ocs et mettre fin à l'occupation
illégale
maintenant l'ordre est rétabli et les
barrages et les scripts les occupations
sont terminés
one way and rock deuxièmement en
évoquant cette loi il nous fallait nous
assurer que nous agissons de façon
correcte nous voudrons toujours défendre
ont éclaté à l'assemblée passé fait
qu'ils allaient liberté d'expression
comme je l'aï dit auparavant cette loi
est écrit pour et manic 2 la charte est
en appui à la charte et ces mesures
devaient donc et on était en conformité
absolue avec la charte est les
parlementaires alors discuté débattu et
nous allons voter nous avons suivi les
procédures et les critiques que nous
continuons ainsi c'est pourquoi un
comité mixte parlementaire sera
constituée afin de passer en revue ses
déclarations dans les 60 jours il y aura
une enquête sur les circonstances
entourant le déclenchement de cette
décision
nous allons analyser comment on s'y
rendent hui pourquoi c'était nécessaire
on pourrait analyser les forces
policières et le financement l'influencé
et la désinformation qui ont soutenu les
barrages et les occupations illégales à
la fois de chez nous comme d'ailleurs
sur les circonstances ayant mené à
l'invocation de la loi sur les mesures
d'urgence elle pourrait porter aussi sur
les activités policières
de plus l' enquête pourrait permettre
d'examiner le financement l'influencé et
la désinformation qui ont soutenu les
occupations et barrages illégaux que ce
soit en provenance d'ici ou de
l'extérieur du pays
finalement le troisième principe être
nous avons été très clair que le recours
à cette loi serait limitée dans le temps
nous avons évoqué la loi
n de pouvoir et sa place comme accents
de 30 jours mais nous avons également
dit que nous allions levé c'est toi le
plus rapidement possible nous avons tenu
des pointes jour tous les jours souvent
plusieurs reprises par jour aujourd'hui
après une analyse soigneuse me sens prêt
a confirmé que la situation
ne fait plus dans l'urgence c'est
pourquoi le gouvernement fédéral
jeu va mettre fin au recours à cette
fois sur le mur d'argent d'urgence nous
sommes confiants que les lois existantes
tout comme les règlements mais les époux
qui suffisent à la tâche de maintenir la
sécurité publique mais sûr nous
continuons d'être là pour appuyer les
autorités locales et provinciales aux
besoins et j'aimerais rassurer les
canadiens et les canadiennes que l'âge
ans d'efforts selon le son du prg est
composé avec toute activité qui n'égale
ou dangereuses les policiers comme les
policières seront là pour protéger le
quartier rue selon leur juridiction
après avoir soigneusement examiné la
situation
on constate qu'on n'est plus en
situation d'urgence c'est pourquoi le
gouvernement fédéral met fin à la loi
sur les mesures d'urgence on juge
maintenant que les lois en place sont
suffisantes pour assurer la sécurité de
la population
évidemment on va continuer de soutenir
les autorités locales et provinciales au
besoin je veux rassurer les canadiens
les autorités sont prêtes à intervenir
auprès de toute personne qui prendrait
part à des activités illégales et
dangereuses
dans le respect de leurs compétences les
policiers vont continuer de protéger nos
rues nos quartiers notre pays
en jetant un regard vers l'avenir ce
serait important de mieux comprendre ce
qui a donné lieu à ce genre de mépris
pour les lois et cette menace à la
démocratie
il nous faut nous assurer que nos
institutions soient mieux préparés à
l'avenir
si c'est une urgence
et met en chose du passé cet enjeu le
mort vivant il ne voudra valley afin de
défendre et améliorer la démocratie chez
nous est un peu partout dans le monde or
tant que nos institutions soient prêtes
à l'avenir et qu'on poursuivre notre
travail pour défendre et améliorer
améliorer notre démocratie que les
lionceaux paintball les canadiens ont
traversé beaucoup d'épreuves il nous
reste bien des me fait rêver rappelons
nous
que nous sommes aux prises avec un virus
et que c'est là le conflit pas entre
nous travaillons ensemble après deux
années difficiles et pénibles nous avons
eu beaucoup de guérison
c'est peut-être le moment on est
solidaires les uns des autres jours
merci
bonjour lundi vous disiez qu'on était
encore en situation de crise aujourd'hui
on n'est plus en situation d'urgence
pourtant à l'extérieur dans le
centre-ville le paysage semble être pas
mal le même
qu'est ce qui a changé dans les deux
derniers jours monsieur le premier
ministre
comment se souvient
les occupations et les barrages illégaux
ont été solidement implanté dans les
rues d'ottawa à nos
traversées frontalière
et avait besoin de plus d'outils pour
les enlever c'est ce qu'on a donné
aux policiers
il ya une semaine avec la loi sur les
mesures d'urgence
en fin de semaine on a vu cette activité
policière ici à ottawa et ailleurs être
réussie pour pouvoir
ramener l'ordre et le respect de la loi
et depuis lundi comme je l'aï dit nous
avons évalué à chaque étape le niveau de
d'urgence de préoccupation et de menaces
qui existent dans le pays et ce matin
nous avions conclu en consultation avec
les différentes forces policières et
disent les experts en sécurité
que les outils dont nos corps policiers
disposent en temps normaux seront
suffisants pour
continuer à maintenir l'ordre dans le
pays maintenant que ça a été rétablie
alors comme promis ne voulions pas
garder une minute de plus
cette loi sur les mesures d'urgence et
donc on annonce que ce sera les vlv
aujourd'hui
puis on comprend que la majorité des
manifestants sont partis mais encore des
manifestations à winnipeg et encore des
manifestants en banlieue d'ottawa puis
le mouvement anti mesures sanitaires
n'est pas mort est-ce que vous avez un
plan si des manifestations de grande
envergure reviennent ou est-ce qu'on se
réserve le droit d'évoquer la loi sur
les mesures d'urgence la prochaine fois
qu'on verrait quelque chose comme ça au
cours des deux derniers jours c'est
justement les conversations que nous
avons eues avec les experts en sécurité
publique avec nous force policière
avec
les ministres pour s'assurer que on est
justement les outils pour contrer cette
menace qui demeure même si l'urgence
n'est plus là la menace
de deux manifestations illégaux de
barricades ou de d'occupation demeure
mais on sait que les forces policières
et les lois que nous avons en temps
normaux sont et seront suffisants pour
pouvoir empêcher d'autres à d'autres
occupations
si y attendait d'eux attroupement
manifestants ils veulent rester où ils
disent ne pas vouloir reculer une réelle
préoccupation qui vont revenir en vue
elle vous prêt à évoquer à nouveau la
loi c'est la police n'arrive pas à
composer avec leur présence sur leurs
activités on pense à une époque où la
vue une autre manifestation centre-ville
réponse
nous savons depuis quelques semaines les
barrages les occupations
ce sont 1 racing à un point tel que nous
avons ressenti lundi dernier qu'il nous
fallait
agir comme gouvernement
tout en offrant des outils
conforme à l'achat mais des outils
supplémentaires à nos forces de l'ordre
oui sera fin de semaine dernière on l'a
vu ce qu'on a vu
et donc à partir de lundi la capitale la
semaine elle n'avait plus de
manifestants ou centre-ville et les
passages frontaliers et l'hébreu on a
passé les quelques derniers jours
discuter avec les différents acteurs
au pays afin de s'assurer que
alors que nous reconnaissions que
l'urgence semblait terminée et que la
menace de murray la menace planait hier
mais que nous disposions des outils dans
le cadre des lois normales sans devoir
invoqué la loi sur mesure d'urgence afin
de composer avec cette menace de retour
et on a un niveau de confiance élevé que
les outils actuels dont disposent les
forces policières au canada suffisent
aux perturbations potentielles question
mais vous allez dis que ce n'est
uniquement tahoua il fallait protéger
des infrastructures critiques des
passages frontaliers les aéroports et
les nommer ils sont tous tous exposés
qu'avant alors qu'est ce qui a changé
réponse est alors écoutez on le vu le
blocage du pont n'est ce pas windsor
elle a pris plusieurs jours
il y avait des questions des enjeux de
juridictions qui ont empêché à la police
de compétences
de pouvoir avancer avec toute la vigueur
nécessaire
afin de déraciner
les occupants de ce pont qui représente
un lien vital pour notre économie
c'est la course et autres passages
frontaliers et n'oublions pas la nature
d'un sauna de la menace c'est ce qui a
mené à cette idée de la loi sur les
mesures d'urgence mais comme je l'aï dit
cela toujours été proportionnel à la
situation est limitée dans le temps
à mesure que nous avons inversé cette
terre dernières semaines nous avons
constaté et on nous assure d'ailleurs
l'autorité policière un peu partout ce
pays qu'ils ont maintenant les outils à
leur disposition
dans le cadre normal de leurs fonctions
de s'occuper des menaces qui planent
donc c'est pourquoi on les prêts à le v
l'application la loi sur les mesures
d'urgence
est ce que ça veut dire qu'ils les
mesures d'urgence ne s'applique plus à
partir de maintenant aujourd'hui 16h20
et qu'est ce qui se passe avec l'argent
qui était gelé les personnes arrêtées
tout ça
les mesures d'urgence vont être révoqué
dès que la gouverneure générale signe la
proclamation ce qui devrait se passer
dans les heures à venir et par rapport
aux halles internations d autres mesures
oui ça veut dire que ces mesures là ne
seront plus en vigueur mais ils ont été
en vigueur pendant dix jours et donc des
des
violations de la loi qui se sont passés
pendant ces dix jours seront
continueront d'être
suivie dans les cours et dans notre
système de justice mais pour ça je vais
je tourne hiver et le ministre la
justice et ensuite la ministre des
finances
merci boris comme le premier vient de
nous dire un fois que la ligue nationale
proclame la révocation la période
d'urgence est terminée mais entre-temps
entre entre la période de la déclaration
et la révocation les les offenses commis
sont encore défaut d offense qui vont
procéder comme n'importe quel autre
france dans le système judiciaire
concernant les comptes la processus de
dé geler les comptes ad
bon alors malheureusement on a perdu le
signal à un moment qui pourtant s'avèrer
cruciale parce qu'on m'a dit avoir
justement ce qui arrivait avec l'argent
qui a été saisi dans les confiseries qui
avait été gelé en fait dans les comptes
bancaires mais tout de même là on a
quand même beaucoup de matériel à
décortiquer avec danielle thibeault mais
d'abord je pense qu'on va pouvoir
retourner au point de presse à la
réponse de madame freeman est ce qu'on
peut y aller
elle va sortir et quand les gens sont
partis à la grc a demandé aux banques de
dégel et des comptes alors ce processus
a déjà commencé mais comme le premier
ministre a dit après la signature du
gouverneur général
le processus va finir je veux juste
souligner qu' il y a des comptes qui
seront toujours gêné mais pas à cause
des mesures d'urgence il y a aussi des
décrets à des cours ecce terra d autres
raisons pour lesquelles les comptes
pouvait être et sont maintenant j'ai les
ans suivi ce que ça veut dire que la
procédure parlementaire devant senna est
terminé maintenant où étaient encore
utile pour que les mesures d'urgence
soit a posteriori valider
le processus
le processus parlementaire qu'on a vu à
la chambre des communes lundi soir
c'était par rapport à l'invocation la
semaine d'avant de la loi sur les
mesures d'urgence le sénat est est un
endroit qui est qui a ses propres
processus il va prendre ses propres
décisions par rapport à ce qui ce qui
est ce qui se passe mais je pense que le
ministre la justice on a un peu plus à
dire là dessus donc
la révocation fait en sorte que la
déclaration n'existe plus donc ce n'est
pas nécessaire pour le sénat de voter
mais comme le prince viennent souligner
ils sont maîtres de leur propre
procédure et donc ils peuvent entamer un
débat là-dessus 7,7 au sénat de décider
le comité parlementaire
ainsi que
l'enquète
sont nécessaires selon la loi et ils
vont procéder
bonjour monsieur trudeau millan crête de
la presse est ce que c'est pas un aveu
que les forces policières avaient déjà
les outils dont elles avaient besoin
mais qu'elle ne les ont pas utilisé
pendant trois semaines au contraire au
contraire ce qu'on a vu pendant deux
semaines ceux que les forces policières
n'avaient pas les outils nécessaires
pour déloger ces occupations qui s'était
implanté et à tahoua et hop un
ambassadeur et à kout est ailleurs et
l'invocation de la loi sur les mesures
d'urgence à encourager certaines
personnes de quitter et d'autre part a
terni aux forces de l'ordre de pouvoir
en finir avec ces occupations
allant vers l'avant on a été assuré que
les forces policières lé pouvoir
utiliser les pouvoirs existants pour
empêcher l'implantation de ces
occupations comme d'ailleurs on a vu
dans des manifestations qui sont venus à
toronto à québec sans devenir des
occupations vous demandez dans vos
réunions pourquoi ils ne l'ont pas fait
quand les camions sont arrivés à temps
c'est une question sur lesquels les gens
vont se pencher j'en suis certain dans
les semaines à venir
marco voulais tu vas faire un
commentaire là dessus
merci merci monsieur le premier ministre
juste pour ajouter que tous les mesures
qui inquiétait à introduire dans la loi
des mesures d'urgence était très ciblé
temporaire et efficace et les preuves de
ces sur le terrain pas seulement on a
trois mais même une époque aujourd'hui
on avait vous pas beaucoup de progrès
même partout à nos frontières dont cas
depuis le début a le gouvernement a
exprimé un désir d'utiliser à cette loi
comme un gagneur et coupe et en même
temps 1 1 préférence pour retire retirer
la loi aussitôt que possible merci
question
est
ce que vous vous encore les campements
de manifestants d'externat toi comme une
menace il avait dit soyons clairs
plaint toujours
que ce soit dans les médias sociaux ou
les gens qui continue de polariser leur
attention sur la manifestation est
peut-être
cela le façon illégale qu'il nous faut
suivre la situation de près mais
l'urgence aiguë qui a mené à l'évocation
de la loi sur les mesures jour il y à
quoi des jours de cela il y avait les
occupations donc vraiment un récit ni
sur le territoire urbain etc la police
n'avait pas les outils ou les ressources
nécessaires pour les déloger de là
je ne sais cette urgence la est
maintenant terminée depuis deux jours
nous avons écouté les experts un jeu
manoeuvre et tact et policière et on
nous dit que les outils de l'art
politique des outils
qu'on le vieux déployés à toronto et à
québec depuis quelques semaines que si
l'autorité la 6 août il a serait
suffisant pour empêcher
même malgré la menace de rétablir des
saccages démarrage que les outils qui
existent en dehors de la loi des mesures
d'urgence suffirait pour infléchir
d'autres urgences
[Musique]
donc vous voyez encore une menace plane
y est ce que c'est une menace à la
sécurité publique une menace à la
démocratie
quels sont les vous un peu expliquer
votre position s'il vous plaît réponse
j'estime que les gens comprennent que ya
eu beaucoup de colère et de frustration
qui est exprimée à l'égard des
gouvernements à l'égard de démocratie ou
mesure sanitaire
qui on est et
comment dire ses frustrations ses
émotions étaient exprimées dans ces
manifestations mais soyons clairs les
gens ont tout à fait le droit d'exprimer
leur désaccord les gens ont toujours le
droit à la libre expression pourront
toujours ça semblait librement au canada
mais vous l'avez quand même pas le droit
de bloquer la voie publique et de causer
des perturbations dans le quotidien de
luminy de concitoyens de faire courir
le père il attend d'emplois dans le sud
antérieur ce droit là non il n'existe
pas et donc on va veiller là dessus
bonjour monsieur trudeau on entendu
depuis hier plusieurs sénateurs
se plaindre l'accueil à des informations
confidentielles mais gardé confidentiel
des informations de renseignement qui
ont contribué la justifier
l'invocation de la loi sur les mesures
d'urgence et pour ce scénario il se
sentait un confortable de se prononcer
sur le bien fondé
mais là maintenant que c'est révoqué
voyais avons une enquête publique et le
comité qui va être mis sur pied est-ce
que je peux garantir qu'ils vont avoir
accès à ces informations
jusqu'ici gardée confidentielle
depuis le début nous avions nous nous
avons commis d'être transparent et
ouvert dans la mesure du possible avec
les canadiens par rapport à
l'utilisation de cette loi sur les
mesures d'urgence mais comme vous dites
et il va avoir un comité parlementaire
où siègeront aussi des sénateurs qui
vont pouvoir
faire un suivi sur les décisions prises
et les actions prises et aussi une
enquête qui permettra d'approfondir
encore plus je pense que
une des choses très importantes dans
tout cet ces dernières semaines ça a été
de renforcer et d'assurer la confiance
des canadiens
dans nos institutions dans nos services
policière dans notre capacité
d'assurer la sécurité et la stabilité de
nos quartiers de notre pays est une
partie importante de cette confiance ça
va être effectivement la transparence et
d'ouverture par rapport aux raisons pour
laquelle on a dû amener cette loi sur
les mesures d'urgence de façon
responsable
limité et temporaire et nous allons
continuer de faire tout ce qu'on peut
pour assurer la confiance continue des
citoyens dans leurs institutions
ok donc
est-ce que des informations
donc ici ont été gardés confidentiels
qui n'ont pas pu être partagés jusqu'à
présent aux parlementaires vont pouvoir
être communiqués à chaque côté là mais
ma fille question c'était plus sur la
formation de ce comité là à quel moment
vous voulez vous
l'annoncer sa formation et il commence
sa composition va être déterminées dont
combien de sénateur combien de députés
de quel parti donc vous nous donner un
peu de détails aujourd'hui sur qui est
envisagée dans la composition
tout d'abord la loi sur les mesures
d'urgence établi en 1988
exige d'ailleurs qu'on crée un comité
joints de députés et de sénateurs
en dents de sept jours
pour pour se pencher sur
cette loi sur les mesures de
l'utilisation de la loi sur les mesures
d'urgence et nous allons absolument
faire ça le parlement doit siéger pour
créer ce comité donc on compte le créée
en début de semaine prochaine et par
rapport à la constitution par rapport à
la participation des différents un
député ça va être soumis à des
négociations avec les autres partis pour
trouver un consensus à pour établir la
bonne niveau ii le bon niveau de
transparence et de de légitimité à ce
comité là mais on va entamer ce travail
les conversations sont des gens thani
type entame et on espère voir ce comité
créé en début de semaine prochaine
quels sont
pour vous avez vous ressenti que
vouliez vous assurer que les ex titution
soient prêtes à l'avenir si jamais nous
devions revivre de tels scénarios tiff
éviter un tel un rationnement de
manifestants
seront peut-être eux aussi j le préparer
avec des mobiles du sinistre d'où toute
réponse écoutez nous avons certainement
des leçons à tirer des dernières
semaines il nous faut réfléchir sur eure
policières compétentes
sont en mesure
de composer avec des menaces nouvelles
la mobilisation massive par les médias
sociaux par exemple
de genre extrêmement motivé ça c'est un
élément qui a de nouveau et donc il faut
se doter d'outils en conséquence
pensons également à l'information et la
désinformation
comprendre comment l'argent étranger une
influence étrangère
dans cette tentative a porté atteinte
voire déstabiliser noté macrez si bien
nous devrons tous y réfléchir j'espère
que nous pourrons le faire de manière
réfléchie clean et respectueuse de
l'éventail des horizons politiques et
des voix qui s'expriment et toujours
toujours à protéger les droits et
libertés fondamentales des qualités et
elle fait définis dans la charte est
telle que tous les crises et les canaux
quotidien
question
il ya beaucoup de gens qui pensent qu'en
évoquant cette loi c'est un précédent
ils vendent à sassenay d'assassinât il
n'y avait pas vraiment d'émeutes y avait
pas de menace de miliciens qui arborait
les rues donc la chaîne semble plutôt
bas pour l'invocation d'une telle loi ce
n'est pas dans un précédent dangereux
mais ce trou d'où réponse
écoutez on l'a vu les policiers réagir
leur modération et les outils tout à
fait proportionnée quand est proposé
avec une conformité absolue catégorique
à la charte est donc
avec des processus dans redevabilité
poste factor que ce soit le comité des
parlementaires ou les enquêtes n'ont en
fait
c'est qu'ils contestent le recours à la
loi sur les urgences je ne crois pas que
l'on dise que lorsque vous
gérez n'est pas conforme à la réalité
vous vous trompez en
prétendant que la barre et 6 passes
cette loi n'a jamais été évoquée
auparavant et nous savions que nous
serions le scruter à la loupe et c'est
pourquoi nous avons pas la résistante
mais attention sur le caractère
proportionnel sur le caca raisonnable et
comme nous l'avons démontré très limité
d'un tort la preuve c'est justement le
fait qu'on suspend l'application de
cette loi de toute façon la loi prévoit
un maximum de 30 jours on a pu
certainement à maintenir trois semaines
de plus n'est ce pas mais on s'est
engagés on savait fort bien
nous allions réévaluer la situation à
chaque jour et c'était la clé justement
pour prouver notre bonne foi une bonne
volonté
nous savons fort bien que les menaces
continuent de planer sur les démocraties
du monde entier et cela nous inclus on
ne veut pas reculer devant les outils
nécessaires pour protéger les citoyens
comme les citoyennes et c'est exactement
ce que nous avons fait encore une fois
je le répète de façon responsable et
proportionnel madame dernière question
[Musique]
sourire debout comme étant le premier
ministre à avoir invoqué cette loi sur
les mesures d'urgence et controversés
comme décision vous dites c'était
nécessaire mais elle vous déçu sur le
plan personnel dans les trains arriver
là
je pense que nous devons tous réfléchir
à ce qui à ce qu'on a vécu un sens au
cours des deux dernières années parce
que pour moi l'histoire de cette
pandémie c'est pas une histoire dure jeu
c'est d'occupation est une histoire de
gens qui ont été là les uns pour les
autres les travailleurs de première
ligne qui ont continué à être là pour
nous protéger pour nous appuyer des
personnes des travailleurs dans nos
hôpitaux a qui ont fait des sacrifices
énormes qui ont travaillé extrêmement
fort pour nous garder en vie des néo
canadiens qui ont été leurs pour leurs
voisins qui ont été là pour la petite
entreprise qui ont été là les uns pour
les autres en se faisant vacciner en
portant des masques cessons
le legs de cette pandémie et ça continue
donc oui c'était désolant de voir
l'impact de cette pandémie qui a tourné
plusieurs vers la la la furie vers des
actes illégaux pour manifester contre la
pandémie contre la science contre les
gouvernements
mais c'est pas ça qui veulent avoir
défini notre pays pendant ces moments
difficiles notre pays reste toujours
défini comme étant un des pays avec le
plus haut taux de vaccination de tous
nos pays perd avoir été un pays où
l'économie a rebondi plus vite
qu'ailleurs parce qu'on était là pour se
soutenir les uns les autres je comprends
que ça fait les manchettes au cours des
dernières semaines mais c'est pas ça
l'histoire de la pandémie c'est pas ça
histoire du canada
le recours aux forces armées je le dis
avec quelques semaines c'est le dernier
né der veer cours mais un pur jean s'est
terminé comme vous dites est ce que vous
pouvez nous dire si un déploiement des
forces armées a été envisagé à un moment
où un nom durant ces barrages
quand on est en train de regarder un
état d'urgence et d'évoquer une loi
comme la loi des mesures d'urgence on se
doit de considérer toutes les
différentes options mais je peux vous
dire qu'on a toujours été extrêmement
loin du point où on a dû regarder et
envisager sérieusement
l'appel aux forces armées comme on a vu
en fin de semaine ici à ottawa les
forces policières qui étaient là en
grand nombre ont ont démontré une
capacité un professionnalisme
impressionnant et on était très contents
de savoir que on n'avait pas et on n'a
même pas commencé à s'approcher du point
où il aurait fallu qu'on appelle les
forces armées parce que nos forces
policières ont fait une très bonne job
score
merci tout le monde
la loi sur les mesures d'urgence aura
finalement duré neuf jours elle avait
été invoquée le 14 février lundi soir
elle avait été la motion avait été
adoptée à la chambre des communes est là
aujourd'hui ce que justin trudeau dit
c'est que la situation n'est plus
urgente la loi sur les mesures d'urgence
donc n'est plus nécessaire elle a
rencontré les objectifs qui lui avaient
été accolé au départ mais là maintenant
donc daniel est avec nous daniel donc
pour le gouvernement la situation ne
requiert plus que cette loi sur des
mesures d'urgence soient en vigueur
voilà ce comme suit le dos laissant
entendre essentiellement c'est que quand
les manifestations commencent et où
quand et sont installés là quand ces
manifestants étaient campés solidement
centre-ville d'ottawa à kutch à windsor
on avait atteint un point où les forces
policières va pas entre les mains les
outils dont elles avaient besoin pour
déloger ces manifestants lèvent faire
avancer pas bouger les choses
essentiellement et dylan la loi sur les
mesures d'urgence pour ça qu'on l'adopté
et là aujourd'hui d'un contexte actuel
avec une révision qui est fait sur une
base quotidienne plusieurs fois par jour
et après une série de conversations avec
des corps policiers aussi je te dire on
peut la levée maintenant les policiers
nous ont dit on a les outils nécessaires
pour poursuivre le travail dans le cadre
de nos juridictions ce sont les corps
policiers qui disent alors dans ce
contexte la fin de la loi sur les
mesures d'urgence - dix jours donc ça va
être elle est techniquement la ccc
c'est une formalité mais ils font que
fernand générale signent les documents
nécessaires pendant ce temps là en
parallèle il ya lieu road watford dans
l'ontario qui a annoncé que à compter de
17h ce soir là
l'application de l'état d'urgence en
ontario était également levé rappelez
vous on avait on avait imposé l'état
d'urgence en ontario quelques jours
avant que le fédéral fasse la même chose
à ce moment là on tentait de réagir à la
fermeture de la frontière à la hauteur
de windsor voilà aux ambassadeurs et et
parallèlement à ça et ça s'est passé
pendant que monsieur bruno parlait on a
mis fin au débat aussi à la chambre donc
la motion est ainsi l'humanité c'est
donc tout ça voilà tout ça est terminé
maintenant ça veut pas dire quand on
ferme la porte surtout il ya encore une
révision automatique qui est prévu par
la loi quand les travaux de la chambre
vont recommencer la semaine prochaine il
y aura un comité qui va être formé de
parlementaires de sénateurs qui vont se
pencher sur le pourquoi du comment cette
loi là a été invoquée à quel moment pour
quelle raison on est là on en est arrivé
là qu'est ce qui a mené à tout ça et
faire un peu le top 6 si vous voulez de
tout cela ça veut dire que les mesures
maintenant les mesures
prévues dans la loi sont levés wynants
alors et puis question gelé les comptes
bancaires par exemple les actifs
comprimés mais monsieur médicinaux sur
le métier a dit programme général a dit
ce qui s'est passé par contre pendant
que la loi était impliqué est en vigueur
les gens qui ont été arrêtés les enfants
soient été commis cela et poursuivre
poursuivre leur chemin devant les
tribunaux alors ça c'est bon c'est pas
terminé de ce côté là je me trompe
daniel on n'a pas eu de réponses
précises quant à savoir qu'est ce qui a
changé entre la situation de lundi soir
où l'on disait que la loi était
absolument essentiel et aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas une réponse précise si ce
n'est que
les policand policiers l'analyse
quotidienne
laisse croire aux gouvernements qui les
mesures d'exception le champion
nécessaire l'autre élément qui a été
mentionné à la toute fin je le mentionne
pas ce que ses revenus à quelqu'un
quelques reprises un discours le recours
à l'armée question lui a été posée très
très directement plutôt est-ce que ça a
été évoqué ça a été réfléchi à un moment
donné mais autrement dit toutes les
options étaient sur la table mais on a
toujours été très très loin du moment où
il fallait appeler les forces
canadiennes en renfort dans ce dossier
effectivement très intéressant mais on
dit tout à l'heure en gouvernement avait
bien dit cette loi ne sera pas en
vigueur une journée une heure de trop
alors visiblement là on a voulu pouvoir
mettre tout cet épisode là le plus
rapidement passant derrière nous alors
c'est fait loi sur les mesures d'urgence
donc qui est maintenant qui est terminée
après 9 jours d'application merci daniel
plaisir
et tout de suite donc pour revenir sur
l'application de cette loi sont des
mesures d'urgence sur ce qui s'est dit
surtout par rapport au temps
[Musique]